well get ready for a whole lot of color
an affordable limited time attraction
launches at the west gate this Friday
speaking of neon yes and believe it or
not that's actually a parking lot it
doesn't look like it right now it is in
all ages outdoor immersive 3D Light
Festival now our Candace Charles is down
there somewhere there's the north
parking lot of the Westgate Candace
hello to my new friend
hi Daddy
any creatures you guys get to check out
here in the eight experiences across
Imaginarium in the north parking lot at
the white skate I'm joined by Gordon
proudy from the Westgate thank you so
much for joining us tell us a little bit
about what people can experience here I
feel date night Vibes a family outing a
little bit of everything oh absolutely a
little bit of everything so you know
it's it's an incredible 3D immersive
experience five million lights 50 000
flowers there's seven fantasy zones over
there and I know we were kind of playing
around a little bit earlier we got a
nice little teas in that one that was
cool yeah and then of course there's
more than 20 of these mystical creatures
that are here like we've met one of them
here and then there's a whole bunch over
here people can wander through mazes
they can uh just do about any experience
that we said family friendly it could be
a great date night check out dinner and
a show either before or after if you're
here for a festival it's a great place
to warm up before that so pretty much
make it make it any kind of night you
want it to be absolutely the Land There
are hands on games a treasure hunt I
hear there's going to be a treasure hunt
you're gonna have to come to find out
more about that fully developing it's
going to be a lot of fun and people are
already talking about that and you know
they've already extended the date till
May 29th because there's so much
interest and demand on the whole uh
event so it's been extended from May 7th
to May 29th nice and you guys are
hearing this I think maybe first we said
10 days but now it's till May 29th
that's exciting thank you so much Gordy
and I'm just saying you look fantastic
man this guy's ready to go we're trying
to get lit at Westgate yes we're gonna
lit hey thank you so much Courtney I
appreciate it and of course you guys can
find out more details on our website
newsnow.com tickets they start pretty
pretty cheap guys 19 bucks for seniors
and children 25 for adults two and under
are free it all kicks off on Friday open
every night at seven o'clock again they
got your details on our website
newsnow.com for now live from the
Westgate in the north parking lot I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now